She's a mom and a nurse and a grandma and a cancer survivor at the same time.
She just inspires me to take on more and more.
I think she's stronger than she thinks she is.
When she knows that we're happy, she gets happy.
If my family was a wolf pack, she would probably be the alpha.
She's always really kind to everybody.
She is the family.
She's definitely the glue that holds us together.
I hope to be as great of a mom as she is.
She's just done everything for us.
If there could only be two people left on Earth,...
...just me and one other person, I would choose her.
Yeah, she makes me feel really special.
She means really the universe to me.
I wouldn't be the person who I am today without her.
You give me confidence to be the lady that I want to be.
You're the mom.
You're the mom!
You should teach other people how to mom.